[Music]
Sudan the largest country in Africa lies
where the Sahara Desert meets the
grasslands of the Sahel
[Music]
since its independence in 1956 civil
wars between sedans north and south have
killed millions and displaced millions
more now a new conflict has emerged in
its westernmost region called Darfur
nearly the size of France this vast
region has been neglected for years by
the government Darfur means land of the
for a Muslim African tribe indigenous to
the area the region is inhabited by many
tribes that are racially and culturally
intertwined but despite these cultural
similarities groups of farmers who are
viewed as African and groups of herders
who are considered Arab have had clashes
over the land for decades
droughts famines desertification and
population pressures have added to the
rising tensions since 2003 rebel groups
have fought against the government
accusing it of supporting the arab
herders over the african farmers the
government's response caused a mass
exodus forcing villagers to become
refugees in their own homeland in this
United Nations refugee camp along the
Chad Sudan border the women and children
here seek asylum from the Janjaweed the
armed militias of Arab herders organized
by the government to fight the rebels
and kill civilians entire villages have
been burned hundreds of thousands have
died beatings rapes and mutilations are
used as weapons of terror
around two million people almost a third
of Darfur s population have fled their
villages these refugees have lost
everything but they are the lucky ones
most still wander the land unable to go
home their lives still at risk despite
international pressure the fighting
still continues and in Darfur the people
are still dying
[Music]